بعد عقدين من الزمن ما زالت تركيبه
السياسيه على حالها في العراق حتى مع
تغيير اتجاهاتها ومسمياتها الكتله
السياسيه الشيعيه المستفيد الاول من سقوط
نظام صدام حسين قبل 20 عاما وتكون حصه
الاسد من نصيبها في نظام ما بعد صدام فهي
اليوم باتت تمسك بمفاصل المشهد السياسي
برمته في العراق وتحت رقابه الحليفه ايران
وسط توازن هش ومتقلب محليا وحتى اقليميا
الصوره تبدو واضحه في الفضاء العام سواء
بصور رجال الدين العراقيين وغير العراقيين
المنتشره في كل الشوارع او من خلال احياء
المناسبات الدينيه التي كانت تقام بالسر
قبل عام 2003 هيمنه على الحياه السياسيه
بعد حرمان دام لفتره طويله من التمثيل
السياسي في ظل النظام القديم الذي اطاحت
به واشنطن حيث شرعت السلطات المؤقته
نصبتها الولايات المتحده في بناء نظام
سياسي جديد مع حلفائها واقامه توازن هش
للسلطه القائم على المحاصصه وتوزيع
المناصب بشكل رئيسي بين الشيعه والاكراد
والسنه مع نسب صغيره لبعض الاقليات
الدينيه والقوميه
طيله هذه الفتره هيمنه الاسماء نفسها على
البيت الشيعي وهي التسميه التي اطلقها
المراقبون على الطبقه السياسيه التقليديه
من نور المالك وهادي العامري وعمار الحكيم
والقائمه تطول كما ان اساسيات النظام لم
تتغير الى حد كبير فالقواعد التي ارسلتها
النخبه في عام 2003 وحتى 2005 مازالت تحكم
الحياه السياسيه حتى الان
تضارب المصالح والبحث عن النفوذ داخل
اركان البيت الشعير دفع الخلافات للظهور
الى العلن لتبلغ ذروتها في اعقاب
الانتخابات التشريعيه الاخيره في عام 2021
لتتحول بعدها الى صدام مسلح على اسوار
المنطقه الخضراء في اغسطس 2022 بيوم من
القتال الدام في بغداد وما زال معظم
العراقيين الذين ولدوا بعد عام 2003 يمنون
النفس بدوله يحكمها القانون لينعموا
بخيرات هذا البلد الذي لم يعرف طعم
الاستقرار منذ زمن ليس بالقصير